[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be doing
something a little bit different than
normal
today we're going to be taking a look at
the harry potter concept art
from the chamber of secrets now most
films
video games animations and other forms
of media
use concept art in pre-production it's
an integral part of the production
process
as it helps to provide a rough idea of
what the final project will resemble
it helps people to visualize what it is
they're going to be working on
watching or investing in and while some
productions
veer away from the concept art
altogether when it comes to their final
products
others remain fairly consistent with it
the harry potter books were massively
and i mean massively popular and the
harry potter filmmakers
wanted them to become an equally popular
film franchise
the harry potter world is vast there are
so many settings
creatures and other things that needed
to be adapted from the books
and so warner brothers hired a multitude
of concept artists
the goal was simple transform these
magical words
into an equally magical visual format
for each film
this concept art was produced and in
today's video
we're going to be taking a look at some
of artist adam brockbank's work
that pertains to the chamber of secrets
he's a massively talented artist
and i think that he did some amazing
work but i want to compare
his concepts to the finished product and
see how similar they actually are
i'm going to be jumping around a bit
from art piece to art piece
and providing you all with some
commentary if you enjoyed this style of
video
then let me know down in the comment
section below and i can do something
similar for the other films
first up we have the hogwarts carriages
departing from the school at christmas
time
it's a beautiful snowy setting with
white horses pulling red carriages
and hogwarts speaking through in the
background this is a beautiful piece of
concept art
something you could put on a wall and
it's remarkably similar to the film
this is what the film ended up looking
like look how close it is
it's almost exactly the same brock bank
did a great job at sketching it up
and the filmmakers set and costume
designers did an excellent job
of replicating his sketch next up we
have some concept art featuring a
character that you all know and love
but might not recognize here this is
young hagrid
the same hagrid that is framed by tom
riddle in his schoolboy days
he definitely looks like a hogwarts
student however the concept art
in this instance though impressive
definitely does not resemble the final
product
though he doesn't appear for long in the
film adaptation of the chamber of
secrets
we do see a glimpse of young hagrid and
though it's workable
it certainly doesn't resemble what brock
bank sketched up
next up we have the king of spiders
aragog himself
this piece of concept art depicts harry
and ron walking toward aragog in his
lair
it's a great piece of art with beautiful
colouring and the film ends up
resembling this
quite closely the aragog in the art
looks very close to the film adaptation
however he does appear to be a little
thinner and certainly scaled down
a little bit next up we have the flying
ford anglia
in aragog's lair this shows the
weasley's blue forward
wailing toward a gigantic aragog i don't
have a frame that matches this exact
concept art
but the overall tone mood established by
the art
is certainly replicated in the film next
up we have a recently petrified mindy
granger
this piece of concept art depicts
hermione immediately after a run-in with
the basilisk
from the chamber of secrets it's a very
chilling dark piece of art that almost
feels more fitting for the later films
as the overall tone of the chamber of
secrets was still quite innocent
if we compare it to the film version we
can see that the general idea is there
however hermione doesn't look quite as
necrotic
either one would have worked for me i
think next up we have the
howler concept this piece of art depicts
a howler a magical letter in red
envelope that no one really wants to
perceive howlers enchant the sender's
written message into their voice
and are generally quite a lot to cope
with in the film we see ron receive a
howler
and it seems to resemble the concept art
quite closely it's not quite the same
but we get the idea and i don't
necessarily think that one is better
than the other
next up we have the hogwarts ghosts
concept this particular piece of concept
art
of course depicts nearly headless nick's
deathday party a congregation of the
deceased
inside the walls of hogwarts the death
day party is of course omitted from the
film
but this piece of concept art does a
good job at giving us an idea of what
the ghosts
are supposed to look like if we compare
it to actual ghosts that appeared in the
film
the idea is clearly there next up we
have the harry quidditch concept
this piece of concept art depicts harry
in a quidditch match
reaching for the snitch with draco
malfoy close behind
this is a great piece of concept art and
there's actually a frame from the film
that nearly exactly resembles it if we
look at the real version
there are a few differences but this is
excellent execution
of turning concept art into reality next
up we have the forks
basilisk concept this piece of concept
art depicts forks
clawing out the eyes of the basilisk
inside of the chamber of secrets
effectively giving harry a fighting
chance it's an impressive piece of art
and it's beautifully drawn if we look at
the film version there are certainly
some differences
but it gives us the right idea in the
film version
i'm not sure if it's just perspective or
not but he appears to be smaller
additionally the basilisk looks less
like a regular snake
and more like some kind of mythical
beast and last but not least
we have the forks ash concept this piece
of concept art depicts forks
a phoenix being reborn from the ash
after bursting into flames
phoenixes are famously immortal but
periodically die
only to be reborn again if we look at
the film version
it's cute but i think that the concept
art looks a lot cooler
and that's it for this video what did
you guys think of this concept
art which versions did you prefer of
each
if you guys want more videos like this
then let me know down in the comment
section
below until next time you're wizard
[Music]
harry